So, let's talk about something huge in
weight management. How in the world do
you quiet down those constant cravings?
Today, we're going to dig into the
science behind a super important hormone
called GLP1, and we'll break down a
nutritional strategy that's all about
working with your body. It's called the
YGY GLP1 30-day system. But first, let's
kick things off with a question that
honestly probably hits home for a lot of
us. Why does trying to lose weight feel
like such an impossible uphill battle? I
mean, you've got the motivation, you've
got the plan, but it still feels like
you're literally fighting your own body
every step of the way. Well, it turns
out it's not just in your head. It's not
about a lack of willpower. Your body is
biologically hardwired to fight back
against weight loss. The moment you
start cutting calories, your metabolism
can hit the brakes and your brain starts
screaming for more food with intense
cravings. So yeah, that feeling of an
internal war, it is very, very real. And
you know what? That internal battle
actually has a name. It's called food
noise. Just think of it like constant
static in your brain. That little voice
that's always thinking about the next
meal, the random cravings that pop up,
the old habits that are just so hard to
break. It's this noise that can totally
derail even the most perfect plans.
Okay, so that's the problem. But what if
your body also had a built-in ally in
this fight? Let's talk about GLP1. This
is a hormone your body produces all on
its own, and it plays an absolutely
crucial role in managing your appetite.
So, how does this ally actually work?
Well, it's pretty cool. When you eat,
your body releases GLP1. It then travels
up to your brain and basically sends a
message that says, "Hey, we're good down
here. We're getting full." That signal
is what helps turn down the volume on
all that food noise, acting like your
body's own natural off switch for
hunger. Now, this whole GLP-1 thing is
getting a ton of attention right now,
and there are two very different ways
people are trying to harness its power.
On one side, you have powerful
pharmaceutical drugs, and on the other,
you have a targeted nutritional system.
Let's really break down the difference
between the two. And right here is the
biggest difference in how they work. The
sources explain that GLP-1 drugs are
what you call agonists. Now, think of an
agonist like a master key. It's not your
body's original key, but it's designed
to fit the lock perfectly and force it
open. These drugs go in and directly hit
your GLP-1 receptors. The nutritional
system, on the other hand, is trying to
be more like a locksmith, giving your
body the tools it needs to make more of
its own natural keys. And this slide,
this highlights a massive difference in
timing. Your body's natural GLP-1 signal
is super quick. It does its job for
maybe a minute or two and then it's
gone. But according to the sources, the
drug approach keeps that I'm full switch
flipped on not for a couple of minutes,
but for 5 to 7 days. That is a
completely different level of intensity.
Now, that sustained long-term activation
is what makes these drugs so effective,
for sure, but it's also what has started
a much bigger conversation about
potential side effects. The sources we
looked at mentioned concerns some users
have brought up like major digestive
issues or muscle loss. And it's exactly
this conversation that's making people
look for alternative nutritional ways to
support GLP1.
So with all that as context, let's pivot
and take a closer look at this
nutritional approach. This specific
30-day system is built on three separate
parts that are all designed to work
together. So here it is, the whole
system. As you can see, it's all about
these three products, and I kind of like
the names, elevate, activate, and
regulate. Each one has a very specific
job to do in this whole strategy. So,
let's break down what each one actually
does. First up, we've got elevate. This
is a daily shot, and its main goal is
right there in the name to give your
body the key nutrients it needs to
elevate its own natural production of
GLP1. The whole idea with Elevate is to
help you feel fuller faster and turn
down that food noise. A key part of it
is something called postbiotics. So, if
you think of probiotics as the little
factory workers in your gut, postbiotics
are the amazing things those workers
make. They're the finished product and
they do a ton of the heavy lifting for
your gut health. In fact, the source
material says that the ingredients in
Elevate have been shown in studies to
help the body increase its natural GLP-1
levels by almost three times. All right,
so that's part one. Part two is the
activator or activate. Now, if elevate
is all about making more GLP-1, activate
is all about protecting it. This is
where the synergy really kicks in.
Remember how we said your natural GLP-1
only lasts for a minute or two? That's
because your body has these enzymes that
break it down really fast. While
activate has ingredients like Larginine
and resveratrol, which the source says
basically act like bodyguards for your
GLP1, helping to protect it so that
feeling of fullness can last longer. And
that brings us to the third and final
piece of the puzzle, the fiber, which is
called regulate. This part of the system
offers support in a more let's say
physical way. You know, fiber is just a
powerhouse. First, it adds physical bulk
in your stomach, which helps send
another one of those full signals to
your brain. Second, it kind of acts like
a gentle scrub brush for your digestive
tract. And third, this is a prebiotic
fiber, which means it's the food that
feeds all those good probiotics in your
gut, supporting your overall health from
the inside out. Okay, so we've got the
three parts, one to boost, one to
protect, and one to support. But how
does it all come together? Let's look at
the actual 30-day plan. The whole thing
is designed in phases. You kick things
off with 10 days of the Elevate shot
right before your biggest meal to really
get your body's natural production
going. Then for the next 20 days, you
switch over to the Activate packet to
help protect and maintain those levels.
And through it all, for all 30 days,
that regulate fiber is your daily
constant, giving you that foundational
support for fullness and gut health.
Now, on top of those products, the
system also emphasizes two really simple
but critical habits. First is getting
enough protein. This is so important for
keeping muscle while you lose weight,
and it also helps you feel full. The
second is hydration. Just drinking
enough water. This is always important,
but it's especially key for letting that
fiber do its job right. You know, it
really all comes back to this one simple
idea. A quote from the source material
puts it perfectly. If you can conquer
those cravings, if you can quiet the
food noise, that's more than half the
battle in weight management. It's a
great reminder that this is about more
than just counting calories. It's about
managing those internal signals that
drive how we eat. And that kind of
leaves us with a final thought to chew
on. What if the real key to managing our
weight isn't just about the food we put
on our plate, but about the noise inside
our heads? What if the whole goal is
just to find a way to turn down the
volume? Something to think about. Thanks
for joining me for this one.